[Music]
thank you
next world leaders are in Belfast to
Mark 25 years of the Good Friday
agreement but can Northern Ireland ever
move on when the violence of the
troubles has not truly been acknowledged
I'm joined Now by spectator columnist
Douglas Murray and former leader of the
dup and our broadcaster Arlene Foster
Douglas Arlene thank you for joining us
on spectator TV now Douglas you write in
the magazine this week about people who
are involved in the troubles now being
held up and lauded as Heroes and sort of
men of Peace um can you tell us a bit
about that to get us started
uh yes it's something which as I
mentioned in my column inspected this
week it is not new we've just had the
25th anniversary celebrations of the
Good Friday agreement we had of course
Joe Biden flying into Northern Ireland
for a matter of hours then doing a sort
of family trip around uh the Republic of
Ireland for a week or so
um we had the clintons arriving in
Northern Ireland for a conference and a
lot of people claiming uh credit for the
agreement and I mentioned in my peace uh
you know let's not be sort of ungracious
about this the Good Friday agreement has
meant that violence in Northern Ireland
has been down significantly for the last
30 years it's not gone away as many
people on the mainland seem to think
um but we haven't had 3 000 more bodies
thank goodness there's an enormous
amount that an incalculable amount that
must be said for it but one of the
things I say the dissenting note I I I
put in is is one that I've tried to put
in before which is that
um for many of us it remains galling to
see the people and I'm thinking in
particular here of Jerry Adams caught in
a smiling selfie with President Joe
Biden seeing these people being
venerated as men of peace who actually
were exactly the opposite of that and
what I've said and lest anyone think
that I've sort of um you know ignorant
of the things that went on on all sides
here remind people when I wrote a book
on Bloody Sunday 12 years ago I attended
the Savile hearings for many years into
in into the atrocity of Bloody Sunday
um I'm not ignoring problems on any or
all sides but it is exceptionally
galling that as I mentioned in that book
uh the people who said don't shoot
people in the head whatever the
circumstances kept being left behind and
the people who believed in shooting
people in the head for 30 years and then
suddenly said actually let's not do that
and now Lord it as the men of Peace it's
still extremely hard to stomach and I
always fear that when we take the wrong
lessons from history the likelihood of
repeating it is except nationally high
and Arlene what do you make of that I
mean is there a case that some people
will make that we kind of need to put
the fans behind us and not maybe not
turn a blind eye to it but kind of move
on from that or or are you in more
agreement with Douglas there well first
of all I mean I remember the events of
25 years ago very well indeed and I've
listened to various speakers over this
last couple of days talking about the
need to say yes and they should people
should show leadership by saying yes and
actually 25 years ago I said no to the
Belfast agreement and the reason I did
that was because the agreement allowed
terrorists to leave jail
without any attention given in the
agreement to those people who had paid
the ultimate that who had lost their
loved ones whose loved ones had been
murdered uh by the very people that were
being let out of prison and I found that
not only morally objectionable and it
was and is morally objectionable but
also what message was outstanding to
people who had conducted violence for a
long period of time what it sent the
message to them that actually
um in exchange for you stopping your
violence and in exchange for killing
people uh you will now be able to stand
as a member of the legislative assembly
you will be able to come a minister in
the government but yet and we know this
very well don't we the legacy of what
happened all those years ago still
hasn't been dealt with and victims are
still hurting and what I found
incredible yesterday was the Secretary
of State for no Northern Ireland Chris
Heaton Harris at the very large
conference which is largely Americans
coming along and speaking to other
academics and and people from the Irish
government and people from the UK
government and all congratulating
themselves and what a wonderful job
they've done Chris Heaton Harris give a
speech where he praised wait for it the
courage and Leadership of Jerry Adams
and Martin McGinnis
which I I just find very difficult and I
think of all those victims who are
listening to that and I've looked at
some of their uh social media accounts
today and frankly they are absolutely
outraged they're very hurt and this just
isn't victims from one side of the
community to take up Douglas's point
this is victims from right across the
community who feel that they are just
forgotten about and instead we're going
to glorify the people who are actually
involved in murdering people for 25 30
years and what went through your head
Arlene when you saw that picture of
Jerry Adams and Joe Biden together as a
in a selfie well I wasn't incredible you
know I wasn't surprised by that at all
and I'm sure Douglas wasn't surprised
either because uh President Joe Biden um
has long been a friend of the Irish
Republican and a movement
um he was photographed with Rita O'Hare
who was on the run from UK authorities
from 1972 for him her involvement in
relation to the murder or the sorry the
attempted murder of a soldier here in
Northern Ireland she then went on the
run and was wanted up until the time of
her death just a month ago but he had no
difficulty in standing for a photograph
with radio O'Hare so it doesn't surprise
me at all uh that he that he stands for
a photograph with Jerry Adams
and Douglas you mentioned in your piece
that you say after the peace process you
know there's been sort of this poison in
on the Northern Ireland that hasn't been
rooted out I mean do you link it to sort
of the rise in a bit of sectarian
violence that we've seen recently for
example in the run up to the the 25 year
anniversary
um
the problem is that it hasn't gone away
and the Good Friday agreement didn't
make it go away
my own prediction has always been that
the IRA would be back because it was
throughout the 20th century and it was
because the poison tree has not been
uprooted
I mentioned in the piece my late friend
Sean o'callaghan who acted as a double
agent within the Army Council of the IRA
a man who exceptional bravery who's my
great honor to be friends with
um Sean spent the last years of his life
writing among other things a biography
of of James Connolly one of the heroes
of 1916 and I remember when I asked him
why he was devoting his his what time he
had left to this he said Connolly was
the man who radicalized me and made me
do Terrible Things Sean himself as a
young man killed people in Cold Blood
believing this terrible cause he said I
want to go up go back and dig that tree
up I want I I want to to get the poison
out I want to do whatever I can so that
it's not still there so that the poison
tree doesn't keep bearing bloody fruit
but when I look at pictures from the
Kragen in recent days and of of
teenagers who don't remember the
troubles going out with petrol bombs and
gleefully entertaining themselves you
see once again that toxic mixture of
boredom
Romanticism and veneration of violence
that is still there and that's the
cocktail that's the cocktail I mean
remember one of the books that the
Provost and others still hate most is
malachiodocates the the trouble with
guns and the reason they hate it is
because audacity in that book highlights
precisely this you know the way in which
in Republican newspapers to this day
people sort of say you know uh uh
commemorating are are much loved Son you
know who's now with the angels you know
who sort of blew himself up whilst
trying to make an IED to put in a
butcher's shop you know this sort of
toxic poison tree is still there and you
know the politicians in Westminster and
Washington like to think it isn't but it
is and they've done nothing to address
it and in the case of Joe Biden I'm
afraid he and other senior Democrats
like Chuck Schumer who spoke a couple of
years ago the show in Fame conference
calling for United Ireland which is I
always remind people is as outrageous as
an MP from Westminster going to America
and calling for Texas to succeed from
the union Chuck Schumer Joe Biden the
senior Democrats they continue to
actually water the poison tree they
continue to do so read some of the
Boston newspapers on any of this they're
more radical than anything written on
the radical left of the British uh uh
journalistic system I'll indeed take
such a Negative view do you think that
Poison's still there do you think there
is still the capacity for sectarian
violence in Isle in Northern Ireland
part of the difficulty is we allow the
glorification of past terrorism to
continue and whilst of course uh those
of us who live in Northern Ireland are
very thankful that we don't live in the
70s and 80s which I grew up in and and
and I'm really glad that my children
don't have to deal with that on a day
and daily basis but the glorification of
terrorism continues and therefore you
will see the leaders of shin Fein go go
to commemorations for people who frankly
were murderers and uh one that I know
very well is Sheamus mcalwind who killed
a number of people in County fermanagh
tried to kill my own father because he
was a police officer and didn't succeed
on that occasion because he was very
young at that time but he went on to
kill a lot of people and Martin McGinnis
used to go to that commemoration every
year and talk about a what a wonderful
person Sheamus McElwain was and that has
an impact on young people because they
look at that and they say oh this man
must have been a great man and look what
he did for Ireland so-called and that
has an impact and now then you get into
um the situation where young people
today from a republican background don't
think there's anything wrong with
chanting about the IRA who are up there
are they will chant in your face as if
it's some cultural right that they have
to do that whereas in actual fact they
are loading people who used to go out
and murder their neighbors on country
roads in Northern Ireland and it's wrong
and I think government have a
responsibility to deal with that issue
and they haven't dealt with it over this
past 25 years they haven't brought about
reconciliation true reconciliation in
Northern Ireland uh it's just the
absence of violence here so therefore
it's not impacting on people in
Westminster and I I really regret that
because if you're genuine about peace
building then you have to recognize
where the difficulties are and certainly
the glorification is one of the things
that we need to tackle to flip down its
head Arlene though do you think the
unionist side has come to terms with its
own links to violence
well I don't know what you mean by the
union side because you see when Douglas
was first speaking I I was thinking to
myself uh people often in Northern when
they're looking at Northern Ireland
separate us into Catholic and Protestant
genius and nationalists actually it was
the law-abiding people on one side and
the terrorists of all Hues on the other
side and the poor unfortunate Police
Service of Northern Ireland on the ruc
is that there was in the middle trying
to keep those people who were law
abiding safe from uh terrorists or
whatever you on the other side so it it
does get frustrating for those of us who
have lived through the troubles when you
hear people think that because I'm from
a unionist background that I would in
some way be in favor of paramilitaries
from a loyalist disposition I'm not I
think those people shouldn't have been
allowed out of prison either frankly and
should have been dealt with in an
effective way but what happened in 1998
was the prisoners from loyalist
paramilitaries and Republican
paramilitaries were allowed to walk free
and I think that huge thing that
happened then and Tony Blair has made
reference to it uh over this past week
and said it was a terribly difficult
thing but it had to be done well why did
it have to be done why did we not stick
by the rule of law and stick by the
justice system and deal with those
people who wanted to go out and murder
and kill instead we've allowed them to
go free and I think that there are
consequences for that of a generational
nature and we're seeing those
consequences now in places like
Londonderry unfortunately and it has to
be stopped by the way John if I may pick
up and just add to Arlene's Point yeah
of course I think this issue of
equivalency if it is extremely important
I mentioned in the piece I was no fan
ever of the late Reverend Ian Paisley I
thought he was a sort of sectarian bigot
loudmouth of a kind I really don't care
for but the idea even that there was a
sort of equivalency between Ian Paisley
and Martin McGuinness is absolutely
nonsense Reverend Ian Paisley was not
leading torture gangs on a nightly basis
was not getting people to come back to
Northern Ireland in order to murder them
like Martin McGinnis did on on occasions
we can prove the way we have audio
recordings and much more
um and as and as for the The Wider I
just go again on this issue of it
because it's it's as Arlene said yes
there's a sort of ease about making the
equivalency well all sides Etc I'm
talking about the specific thing that
for instance uh remind me so earlier
that Michael Stone was that the madman
yeah yeah take the example of Michael
Stone Michael Stone carried out the set
of sectarian killings uh um in Northern
Ireland including the famously the uh
attack and the cemetery
um of the uh you know during the funeral
of the of the bodies of the people who
brought back from Gibraltar now Michael
Stone was a classic example of a sort of
a radical terrorist extremist from from
the other side okay here's the thing
like nobody is lording Michael Stone
he isn't in a devolved assembly he was
not made as Martin McGinnis was a deputy
first Minister he um was not in charge
of Education in Northern Ireland at any
point
um nobody thinks it's some incredibly
difficult to test to condemn him
we get back to this point that you know
as I mentioned in the piece the current
head of shin feiner the leader of the
opposition in the Irish parliament in
Dublin is taken to be bloodied and pay
homage to Sean Russell a Nazi and former
Ira leader in the 1940s who died on a
German Uber for once the use of the term
Nazi in 2023 is not hyperbole the
current head of shin Fein Mary Lou
McDonald is taken to pay homage at the
Statue of a murderer who was a Nazi who
was leading a buyer campaign against
British cities as the luftwaffe was
bombing those same British cities
and Mary Lou McDonald has to pay homage
why is it what is it about this movement
that means that you still have to pay
homage to Nazis and terrorists and
killers and bombers if you are to rise
in the ranks of the movement does nobody
see the problem here you know this is
what I would like us to see addressed
and I've said before to endless Northern
Ireland ministers you know they've been
endless inquiries inquiry after inquiry
and everybody could have one but somehow
it doesn't get to the root of the
problem
so turning to the Future Arlene do you
know that poison still exists that sort
of glorification of violence and so on
uh do you have any hope for the future
of Northern Ireland do you think this
can be resolved
look uh I've been a politician in
Northern Ireland since I was a teenager
and I think that you have to be an
optimist if you're a politician in
Northern Ireland and I am an optimist
the good people of Northern Ireland
those people who get up every morning go
to work and want Northern Ireland to be
a success will make it a success but
that doesn't deal with the issues that
are still there a remnants from our past
which are still infecting what's
happening here today and that has to be
dealt with and I think instead of
allowing uh Shin fian members to say
that they're just speaking their truth
and they're just remembering their
Patriot dead they should be called out
and it should be pointed out that it is
morally objectionable to Lord people who
went out to murder their neighbors for
no other reason than they put on a
uniform to try and protect citizens in
Northern Ireland that was it and indeed
on many occasions along the border all
you had to be was a Protestant to get
taken out because you maybe had a
Farmland that was near to the border and
they wanted to have it for them uh sold
in a particular way so
look all of that sectarianism all of the
glorification of terrorism must be
called out if we're to make any progress
in reconciling in in a true way in
Northern Ireland and not just talking
about reconciliation
um and if it's an as if it's a nice
thing to do and middle class people go
along and they have a nice time together
and not seen in somewhere to be
reconciliation reconciliation is about
calling out the difficulties and the
real challenges and not just trying to
paper over the cracks and therefore we
have to call out what's wrong and for me
what is wrong is about the past
glorification of terrorism which
continues to infect what's happening
today
all right and thank you very much Alan
and thank you Douglas
next Louise Perry writes the cover piece
for this week's magazine about the
ethical dilemmas of surrogacy
cancerous surrogacy ever be done in a
way that is best for the mother and the
baby Louise joins me now
[Music]